we now have found out more about how
much Donald Trump's Mexican wall will
cost and it ain't pretty Reuters is
reporting that there is a department of
homeland security document which
outlines the details of the border wall
it says that it will be a mixture of
walls and fences covering twelve hundred
and fifty miles of the border not
actually the entire border as Donald
Trump has suggested and it will cost not
four billion not eight billion not
twelve billion dollars but twenty one
point six billion dollars nearly 22
billion bucks that number actually still
seems too small to some research groups
like Bernstein Research it's 1.7 million
dollars per mile still about two or
three times what Donald Trump has
claimed and depending the past depending
on which iteration of Donald Trump's
pass claims you believe it's about eight
billion higher than Paul Ryan's estimate
there's still no coherent plan as to how
Mexico will ultimately pay for the wall
will it be a border tax it's still not
clear abundantly clear is that if it
happens American taxpayers are paying
for the wall up front the estimate also
doesn't include the billions that would
have to be spent in perpetuity
indefinitely to maintain the wall and
here's the kicker it would take more
than three years to build even if they
started within the next few months it's
unlikely that it would be done before
Donald Trump's first term the only term
he currently has would be over and we
should be highly skeptical of this
timeline because it would require
building a mile a day I don't think path
that they can build a mile a day of this
wall and Donald Trump promised the wall
that would be 35 feet high cover the
entire length of the border and I wonder
how much of that 22 billion dollars
would be the cost of that big beautiful
door in the middle of it not much that's
my prediction also that 20 1.6 billion
dollars doesn't include the
environmental costs right it doesn't
include the negative externalities of
the environmental damage that would be
done to build a 1250 mile wall the
Department of Homeland Security also
says there's another issue which is that
they could be stuck in court for years
because they would need to use eminent
domain to seize some of the land on
which the wall would be built and as you
may
no eminent domain cases are not handled
quickly there could be years and years
going well beyond Donald Trump's
presidency of court cases with regard to
eminent domain and of course if any of
this even happened since it wouldn't be
done at the end of Donald Trump's first
term it's very likely that Donald Trump
2020 of adversary or just whoever wins
in 2020 if Donald Trump chooses not to
run for re-election although I know that
formerly he has filed to run for
re-election they may shut down the
entire thing on day one of the next
presidency and all of this would be a
total waste with nothing to show I'm
sure they would if a Democrat was to win
i also just wonder how much the debt and
the deficit is going to increase under
Trump well my god honey 2 billion
dollars isn't too much in the grand
scheme of things I think it goes to a
culture that he just he wants to be a
big spender in office oh the Trump would
be one of the biggest vendors absolutely
and it is yet another horrible
unrealistic solution to a problem that
doesn't really exist because remember
most undocumented immigrants a
significant portion of undocumented
immigrants i should say don't actually
physically cross between Mexico and the
United States we're talking about
overstaying visas we're talking about
people who fly in etc etc we talked
about it before it's it's just
embarrassing and the truncus absolutely
love it today's david pakman show is
made possible in part by zip recruiter
if you are hiring you've probably
figured out that just posting your job
in one place isn't enough to find
quality candidates you should really be
posting to all the top job sites and now
you can with ziprecruiter ziprecruiter
also has nine million resumes that you
can search through in their database you
can add multiple people to your account
so if you're hiring in a team setting
you and your colleagues can work
together to find the best higher and you
can also post your job listing to 200
plus job sites as well as social media
networks like Facebook and Twitter with
one click you can search for candidates
in any city in any industry just post
once and watch the qualified candidates
roll in and the best part for me is with
v ziprecruiter system you can quickly
screen
it's rate them hire the right person
fast without juggling emails and phone
calls all within the ziprecruiter system
and if you do have a question or an
issue ziprecruiter has a friendly human
support team to actually help try
ziprecruiter for free by going to zip
recruiter com forward slash free trial
that's ziprecruiter com / free trial